no
[Música]
los océanos son fundamentales para la
vida en el planeta y hoy en día nuestros
mares están así todos los años ingresan
8 millones de toneladas de partículas y
elementos plásticos a los mares eso es
equivalente a 800 torres eiffel si
seguimos igual al año 2050 vamos a tener
una tonelada de plástico por una
tonelada de peces en los océanos
en enero del 2016 en la reunión del foro
económico mundial en davos la fundación
del sma castro y ocean conservancy
presentaron al mundo este primer informe
que habla de la contaminación plástica
la sala estaba preparada más o menos
para 100 personas no éramos más de 1520
los asistentes
al día siguiente el foro económico
mundial como lo hace siempre con cada
uno de los temas que se desarrolla en
una plataforma tan seguida en todos
lados del mundo lanzó por las redes
sociales este titular más plástico que
peces en los océanos no si podemos
evitarlo esa frase ese titular ha sido
de la frase más seguida y más re
replicada en la historia de las redes
sociales del foro económico mundial
a partir de ese momento la conversación
cambió hoy en día sólo el 2018 25 países
y numerosas ciudades han desarrollado
legislaciones para prohibir o limitar la
entrega gratuita o la venta de productos
plásticos desechables y es que de una u
otra forma el plástico se está
convirtiendo una suerte de villano
global que necesitamos entender mejor
una de los problemas que genera es
cuando es desechado el medio ambiente es
que cualquier mecanismo que usemos para
desechar lo vamos a necesariamente
generar un impacto importante si lo
quemamos aunque sea para generar energía
eléctrica estamos contribuyendo al
calentamiento global si lo desechamos
por supuesto en la basura domiciliaria
ese plástico va a llegar a un vertedero
un relleno sanitario de una u otra forma
va a terminar impactando el ecosistema
terrestre durante siglos y cuando lo
desechamos a través de los cauces de
agua tiene una altísima probabilidad de
llegar hasta una de esas cinco sopas de
plásticos que hay en los océanos dada la
confluencia de las corrientes marinas o
puede terminar en las profundidades de
los océanos o eventualmente contaminando
alguna playa o zona
hemos hecho tremendos esfuerzos en el
último tiempo fundamentalmente en
reciclar en disminuir el impacto a
través de recolectar lo más posible pero
déjenme decirle que si eso es importante
la verdad es que al mismo tiempo no es
más que un paliativo es el equivalente a
tomarse un analgésico cuando se tiene un
infección
por lo tanto lo que tenemos que empezar
a hacer es preguntarnos cómo hemos
llegado aquí para entender un problema
ambiental tan relevante debemos
necesariamente entender el origen
haciendo un paralelo cuando cualquiera
de nosotros ve un río que se contamina
de un día para otro a nadie se le
ocurriría ir a resolver el problema
aguas abajo en la desembocadura al mar
todo lo que hacemos es que caminamos por
el río aguas arriba hasta encontrar
dónde está la fuente dónde está el
origen intentamos resolver ese origen
es lo mismo que tenemos que hacer con la
contaminación plástica es lo mismo que
hacemos con la contaminación atmosférica
entre años 99 y el año 2009 me dediqué a
empacar alimentos esa fue mi ocupación
y la verdad es que hace diez hace cinco
años no teníamos estas distinciones
simplemente usábamos el plástico más
barato que existiera en el mercado para
economizar el sistema y hacerlo más
eficiente
ahora hubo un momento y recuerdo muy
bien el día en que me di cuenta que cada
vez que colocaba un producto en el
mercado estaba colocando dos cosas
estaba colocando el producto pero estaba
colocando también el empaque con una
altísima probabilidad en muchos casos de
que ese empaque se convirtiera en basura
al terminar su uso esta es mi abuela
nació el año 1921 murió hace pocos meses
y tuve la suerte en los últimos años de
su vida poder conversar respecto de cómo
era la vida en su infancia y juventud
y en esas conversaciones aprendí que en
la década de los 40 ella podía resolver
el tema de los residuos fácilmente
entregándoselos a los animales
revolviendo lo con los residuos del
jardín ella no tenía que lidiar con el
problema a la basura como lo tenemos que
ser hoy en día los seres humanos
inventamos la basura hace muy poco
tiempo es que miren como era una tienda
un almacén en la década de los 50
lo que prima y son fundamentalmente
materiales altamente reciclables o
altamente reusables como el metal el
vidrio la madera el cartón y esta es una
góndola de un supermercado de hoy lo que
priman son embalajes plásticos muchos de
ellos aportándole mucho valor al
producto sin esas particularidades
probablemente no podríamos tener el
contenido pero al mismo tiempo la verdad
es que muchos de ellos diseñados para
terminar en la basura
como dice william mcdonough el diseño no
es más que una declaración de intención
y cuando diseñamos un producto plástico
muchas veces estamos diseñando
efectivamente para que ese producto
plástico termine en la basura
ahora cuando hablamos de plásticos
tenemos que necesariamente entender qué
significa plásticos ya que hay un tema
importante porque plásticos hay 4000
tipos de resinas plásticas distintas
cada una de ellas le aporta una
característica al producto tiene
propiedades físico-químicas diferentes
todas ellas se comportan y le dan
atributos ya sea el producto que estaba
fabricado o al contenido del empaque de
modo que si lo que queremos es resolver
el problema plástico
tenemos que entender si existen o no
alternativas de otro tipo de materiales
que efectivamente aporten esas
propiedades al producto o bien si
podemos simplemente movernos hacia
aquellos plásticos que efectivamente son
más sustentables aquellos que son más
reciclables
pero lo primero que tenemos que hacer
también es entender que muchas veces el
problema ni siquiera está en la resina
el problema está en que estamos
colocando en el mercado un producto
superfluo que por diseño está hecho para
terminar en la basura
uno de los excelentes ejemplos para eso
es el sorbete que usamos para tomar
jugos y aquí yo quiero desafiarlo a
ustedes a que hagan un esfuerzo
importante cuando se les presenta la
posibilidad de tomar un sorbete para un
ejercicio yo sé que no es fácil pero
tomen un vaso inclinen el brazo y
acerquen lo
se puede
el problema hoy en día es grave y
tenemos que empezar a hacer cambios
culturales importantes a esas
principales razones por las cuales
utilizamos o no una resina que son
valiosas son razonables existen por
alguna razón estamos agregándole un
quinto elemento y ese quinto elemento es
cuál va a ser el destino que va a tener
ese material plástico cuando yo termine
de utilizarlo la botella es un excelente
ejemplo que ha ido evolucionando hace
ser cada vez más circular cada vez más
recuperable cada vez más reciclable
cuando nos planteamos esta problemática
entre ciclos lo que hicimos fue primero
empezar a entendiendo cómo está
estructurada la lógica de la basura y
nos dimos cuenta que había un sistema
muy bien articulado en el cual los seres
humanos poníamos nuestros residuos
muchas veces en una bolsa negra para que
pasara un camión y se lo llevara
suficientemente lejos para que la basura
desapareciera el camión de la basura lo
único que hace es que desplaza los
residuos y el problema a unos kilómetros
de nosotros y desplaza muchísimos
materiales que son reciclables ahora la
verdad es que además tenemos que
entender que la basura no es otra cosa
que una consecuencia de nuestros hábitos
de consumo lo que hay ahí son decisiones
que nosotros tomamos como consumidores
basados no solo nuestras opciones sino
que además premiando lo que hoy en día
se entiende como economía lineal de
extraer diseñar producir y usar consumir
y finalmente descartar la basura no es
otra cosa que un error de diseño y lo
digo con conocimiento de causa yo diseñé
basura durante muchos años ahora cuando
entendemos eso como un problema
inmediatamente lo que se nos viene a la
imagen es el reciclaje con una solución
y nos tendemos a imaginar estos cachitos
de colores o bien nos imaginamos el
trabajo titánico que hacen los
recicladores de base muchas veces en la
invisibilidad y con condiciones muy
precarias ambos materiales van a parar a
lo que se llama una planta valorizado
ahora y una planta procesadora es un
gran galpón donde un ejército de gente
selecciona entre los materiales aquello
que no es reciclable que llega ahí y que
termina igual en un vertedero en un
relleno sanitario incumpliendo la
promesa de aquello que si es reciclable
y termina en una planta recicladora una
planta recuperadora empecemos también
por cambiar el lenguaje reciclar es
garantizar que el material va a terminar
siendo transformado no es
separar
el sistema hoy en día funciona
recuperando entre un 10 y un 15 por
ciento de los residuos sólidos
domiciliarios lo que es absolutamente
insuficiente tenemos que cambiarlo y la
forma como pensamos nosotros hace 10
años fue el cambio necesariamente tiene
que pasar por el ciudadano ese ciudadano
va a requerir conectarse con la cadena
de valor aguas abajo y por lo tanto lo
que hicimos fue reinventar la planta
valorizado ahora en lo que hoy llamamos
puntos limpios donde las personas pueden
llevar hasta 25 tipos de materiales
distintos pero también lo que hicimos
fue colocar un reciclador de base cuyo
principal rol y la razón por la cual es
pagado no es sólo por el valor de los
materiales es por el servicio que presta
de educar al consumidor esa persona que
muchas veces hemos despreciado en la
cadena de valor y en el sistema es una
persona que tiene un conocimiento
riquísimo sabe de física de química de
materiales de logística muchas veces no
sabe que sabe pero sabe y esa persona
nos puede enseñar una infinidad de
información respecto de los materiales
nosotros después lo que hacemos que
cerramos el ciclo y garantizamos la
trazabilidad de los materiales por lo
tanto aportamos un valor ambiental en
términos de reducirla
de residuos generamos valor para las
marcas que están financiando el sistema
y por supuesto generamos impacto
cultural y social en la interacción
entre el ciudadano y el reciclador de
base ahora lo más importante es no sólo
cerrar el tema de aguas abajo sino que
generar las preguntas aguas arriba
necesitamos consumidores que cada vez
más empiecen a cuestionarse qué es lo
que estamos comprando y créanme en mi
historia antigua yo sé que las empresas
reaccionan ante las expectativas de los
consumidores imaginemos un mundo donde
los consumidores podemos y debemos
empezar a cuestionarnos cada vez más qué
es lo que estamos comprando cuando
compramos un embalaje en esa interacción
nos dimos cuenta que además había un
valor gigante en concentrar esa
información y empezamos a desarrollar
software si empezamos a capturar esa
batalla y tenemos 10 años de información
que hoy en día están usando más de 300
empresas en el mundo entre las cuales
está la más grande empresa de bebidas
del mundo la más grande snacks la más
grande el lácteo el mayor retailer del
mundo están usando información que es
generada no sólo en esta red de puntos
limpios sino que a partir del
conocimiento
experiencia que tienen los recicladores
de base esa información les está
permitiendo hoy en día empezar a pensar
qué materiales usan como empacar los
productos cuántos residuos cuántos
gramos de residuos nos están entregando
cada vez que no entregan un producto
pero fundamentalmente también empezar a
entender mejor los modelos de negocio y
es que hoy en día uno de nuestros
mayores orgullos es cuando una empresa
se nos acerca porque lo que quiere es
fortalecer su estrategia de envases
retornables si bien nosotros nacimos
como la mayor empresa de reciclaje y de
operaciones de reciclaje del continente
hoy en día y hoy en día operamos una
serie de redes de puntos limpios en
distintos países lo que nos interesa es
generar un cambio cultural donde las
empresas aprendan a colocar productos en
el mercado sin que los consumidores
tengamos que comprar el residuo que
viene añadido sabemos que los
consumidores hemos sido parte del
problema tenemos que pasar a ser parte
de la solución y hoy en día lo que
estamos viendo en todo el mundo es que
las empresas han aprendido y están
aprendiendo cada vez más a desacoplar su
modelo de crecimiento de la
contaminación ambiental
para bien hoy en día el planeta ha
pasado a ser un elemento más en la
ecuación que me el éxito empresarial
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]